han pasado 150 días desde que rusia
comenzó la invasión a ucrania y nos
encontramos en la ciudad de kharkiv la
segunda más grande de ucrania y uno de
los lugares que más ha sufrido los
ataques rusos desde el comienzo de la
guerra aquí a mis espaldas solamente se
puede ver una pequeña parte de la
destrucción que dejaron los ataques
especialmente durante los primeros meses
en las últimas semanas las tropas
ucranianas lograron hacer retroceder a
las tropas rusas sin embargo ellas
siguen atacando desde la distancia y
todavía se oyen bastantes explosiones
sin embargo esta fecha este día número
150 llega con la noticia del bombardeo
al puerto de la ciudad de odessa allí
donde estaban los depósitos de grano que
iban a empezar a ser exportados según
ese acuerdo al que habían llegado ayer
en la ciudad de turquía tanto rusia como
ucrania con la intermediación de turquía
y de las naciones unidas- se ha conocido
que dos de los misiles que fueron
lanzados a donde fueron interceptados
otros dos cayeron en el puerto sin
embargo esos depósitos de grano
afortunadamente no alcanzaron a ser
quemados y todavía se mantienen en buen
estado lo que ha llevado a decir al
ministro de infraestructura que siguen
trabajando para poner al día esos
puertos y empezar la exportación de este
grano que es necesario para aliviar la
hambruna en muchos lugares del mundo